uh-oh sounds like somebody needs their
nappy changed better hold your breath is
we check what's inside
triple pasted diaper cream it was
originally developed by summers
laboratories as a prescription-strength
medicated ointment for children's
hospitals and dermatologists now triple
paste does double duty with an
over-the-counter formula - the originals
- of antifungal make on Azure nitrate
otherwise both versions of the product
contains similar ingredients like cereal
alcohol to suppress evaporation since
keeping skin dry but not dried-out is
key to combating diaper rash that's
because liquids increase the
permeability of skin allowing irritants
like urine and fecal enzymes into the
epidermis which is why triple pays to
use a zinc oxide and white petrolatum
aka Vaseline to create a powerful
barrier between baby bum and diaper scum
further strength in malaria is anhydrous
lanolin a purified version of the oil
sheep exude into their wall as a
waterproofing agent while additionally
accelerating the growth of healthy new
skin cells but of all the indignities
caused by sitting in your own poop the
worst may be a candida yeast infection
so triple pastes formula also includes
Oh colonel extract as a mild antifungal
protein bi-stable compounded from
chamomile provides additional
antibacterial support with cholesterol
and polysorbate 80 rounding things out
as emulsifiers though of course the most
important ingredient for making a baby
feel better is what hmm that's right
love
coochie-coochie-coo
feeling wired yet subscribe